Speaker 1: All right, I've got a message for
everybody today, listen very carefully here.
I don't want to be misunderstood.
I don't care if you want to wear a mask forever.
And what I mean by that is I don't mind.
It doesn't bother me.
It's no skin off my back.
It really doesn't bother me at all.
I'm not going to think twice if you want to
wear a mask forever or for years or indoors
or outdoors or whatever, I have no interest
whatsoever in telling anybody not to wear
a mask or worrying about people who plan to
wear masks even beyond when the CDC recommends
it.
But there are increasingly more and more Republicans
who are going off the wall with rage and fury
that other people want to keep wearing masks.
Now, this is actually a really big topic because
fundamentally this relates to the psychology
of the pandemic, pandemic induced PTSD, agoraphobia,
fear adjustment, and a whole bunch of different
things that I'm glad to talk about in a moment.
But fundamentally, this reaction from the
right is the absurd hypocrisy of people who
constantly claim for decades they've been
claiming we're about liberty, individual freedoms,
letting people do whatever they want, as long
as it doesn't infringe on someone else's freedom
to do what they want.
They are all about letting others do whatever
the hell they want to do.
And they will not stop talking about others
who want to keep wearing masks of no consequence
whatsoever to Tucker Carlson or to whoever
doesn't want to wear a mask, let's look at
some examples.
Here is a recent headline from a Fox News
Tucker Carlson interview with Brit Hume called,
quote, Some people want to wear their masks
forever.
It was a segment dedicated to ridiculing and
criticizing people who may be vaccinated but
want to continue wearing a mask.
Here is a segment from Fox News where reporter
Peter Doocy either feigns confusion or is
really confused about why Joe Biden wore a
mask inside a Ford auto plant earlier this
week despite being vaccinated and despite
the CDC guidelines now saying, you know, vaccinated
people really don't have to wear masks in
most situations, including indoors.
Let's take a look at this segment.
Speaker 3: But the president is saying a lot
by showing us what he's wearing.
We have some new video you can see at a electric
vehicle plant in Dearborn, Michigan.
He has got a face mask covering his mouth
and nose, which conflicts with the CDC guidelines
that you don't have to do that or socially
distance indoors or outdoors as long as you
are vaccinated, which the president has been
since before taking the oath of office.
Speaker 1: Now, when it comes to that specific
event with Joe Biden at the Ford plant, and
I believe it was Michigan, remember that the
CDC guidelines are not state policy and the
CDC guidelines have not yet been made state
policy in many places and state policy and
state law supersede recommendations from the
CDC.
At the end of the day, they're just recommendations.
And, of course, Ford, not just Michigan, Ford
may well still have a policy that everybody's
masking indoors, regardless of vaccination
status.
Many retailers still do, et cetera.
But fundamentally, putting that aside, who
cares if other people want to wear masks?
As I've said before, I don't believe the outdoor
masks were ever really necessary in almost
any situation.
But I did it in order to be a team player
because those were the CDC guidelines and
or state guidelines.
And as soon as the CDC said masks are no longer
recommended outdoors for vaccinated people,
I haven't worn my mask outdoor since other
than in specific situations like waiting in
line to get into a grocery store where the
grocery store recommends it.
Now that the CDC has said basically every
activity for vaccinated people is low risk,
I'm seeing other vaccinated people.
And the truth is, everybody I know is vaccinated
at this point, but I'm seeing vaccinated.
People indoors were not wearing masks.
I've even sat inside of some cafes.
But when I see people outside wearing a mask,
I don't care.
I don't give it two seconds of thought.
If I if I devote some thought to it, I might
wonder, well, maybe they're not yet vaccinated.
OK, so they're wearing a mask.
Maybe they have a particular situation medically
where they are at risk, or maybe they just
like covering their face.
Or maybe they're afraid because it's been
14 months of this and it takes time for people
to readjust or whatever.
Who cares just because it's not the CDC recommendation
and just because I'm not doing it?
What do I care if other people are doing it?
As long as they are not berating me to do
something that is not part of the CDC recommendation?
So this is yet another one of those instances
in which the hypocritical right wingers claim
to have certain values, but they don't stand
by them when the rubber meets the road.
Now, the other reality we also should mention
is that any guidelines where there is a degree
of nuance, where you need more than one sentence,
it's probably too complicated for the people
that watch Fox News.
So it wouldn't be surprising to me if the
reason imagine that we looked and like maybe
Michigan has pulled the mask mandate and maybe
Ford did, too.
I don't know.
It looks like everybody was wearing a mask
there.
So Ford probably requires it.
But imagine that Ford said you don't have
to wear masks if your resident vaccinated.
Michigan said the same thing.
If Fox News viewers turn on the TV and absent
any context, they just see Joe Biden walking
around with no mask, many of them are going
to immediately take their masks off in all
situations, even around vaccinated people,
because they don't understand what the hell
is going on.
So in some sense, you could make the case
it makes a lot of sense for the president
of the US to keep wearing the mask when he's
going to appear on TV and in public so that
unvaccinated Fox viewers don't see it and
assume they're clear to just do whatever the
hell they want despite not being vaccinated
and despite being indoors around other unvaccinated
people.
So, first of all, I don't care what other
people are doing with their masks, power to
them to do whatever they want.
But at the same time, because we have so many
ignorant people in the United States, in a
way, it kind of makes sense that this is exactly
what Joe Biden would be doing.
So come on, guys, just live your life, get
yourself vaccinated, follow the CDC guidelines.
Don't worry about what other people are doing.
Let them do whatever they want.